hopefully after tonight Colton won't be
a virgin anymore demi makes a bold move
Colton admits he's falling in love and
multiple girls make a surprising exit
all during a week six of The Bachelor
terrifying that's my greatest fear and
honestly I'm gonna end up with someone
who's not here to be engaged something
this Sidney realized it was the end of
the road for her if it was right it
would be a lot easier than it husband
between the two of us so I just don't
think that we can get there based on
Nene just meaning more because of that I
am gonna go home today while Demi's
connection with Colton seemed to thrive
the pair even called her mom Tina on
their group date who was recently
released from federal prison hopefully I
look forward to introducing Colton to
you in person
[Music]
I love you more
it was nice meeting you
but later when Demi made a surprise
visit to the former NFL stars bungalow
two seemingly deflower him he sent her
packing I now feel like I am falling in
love with you
I just want time to be able to like
enjoy each other and to just like let
myself fall I do think about you a lot
and I do think about us but there's a
part of me that just that just doesn't
know if we can get there I just I don't
know right now if I can see myself with
you at the end of this
I can't sit here and after hearing that
tonight and put you through a rose
ceremony although there was plenty of
drama on Monday night's episode Colton
also got closer with Hanna ji admitting
this she makes me feel special somebody
who I wanna make feel special every time
I'm around her
take a picture Anna being my wife
after tonight
they say that I'm falling in love with
Hannah I am falling in love with him
gets scary but it was really really good
in the end Colton was left questioning
his decisions after not one but three
girls told him some women weren't there
for the right reasons the third person
said about what he sidney's that issues
talking about dummy
he was talking about and then I say
goodbye to Katie and I don't know who
she's talking about what listen
something from next week's teaser it
looks like the drama will continue
Dalton
[Music]
oh my god
we do it here up till now nobody knew
the truth et recently sat down with
Colton where he dished on his strategy
when it came to dating so many women on
TV I did things my way and I changed the
game but nothing can prepare you for
this I don't have is it normal to date
30 women at one time I don't know well
you tell me no it's not oh are you still
a virgin do would you want me to spoil
that for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]